we're going to talk about style you know
it was just fashion week and from milan
to paris and the new york times reports
that one shape was everywhere drew and
it was the suit and it's not just gucci
and versace there's a huge trend of
people taking off their sweatpants
um i'm looking at you because i wear
them too much i know every morning it's
had to do every day even on dates and
then my friends get mad at me
like well they should know the real deal
but
look what's happening
like if you're not into netflix and take
out we should just not bother
yes
i like you in sweatpants i'm just this
was fashion week all right so what's the
latest in fashion rossi well it's the
it's suits for women check out zendaya
there's zendaya yeah sandra
all right
these gold colors sandra oh sophia bush
that is okay your sweatpants are cute
but hello yeah no he doesn't compare
with that those three gorgeous women but
you show up you you do show up for
fashion and in fact check out this
fashion maven at new york fashion week
yep i'm wearing hello that's you in a
suit you're the tr you're on trend oh
good oh it's christian siriano put me in
that suit thank you christian
he is such a good friend he gets me out
of the house he gets me out of
sweatpants yeah
all right well um this is interesting i
recently did my first zoom date and it
wasn't as weird as i thought it was
going to be i think because we've all
been so accustomed to zoom at work and
you know with friends and we're all sort
of zoom
literate right now
we speak zoom well this story really
spoke to me because it's about the zoom
world the albuquerque journal reports
that animal welfare department there has
started a virtual dating service to link
pets and potential owners
people looking to adopt can zoom date
with a pet first to check out their vibe
before they meet in person and the
foster parents will operate the zoom for
the puppy or the kitty because you know
they have no hands oh yo they can't
except for if you're douglas my dog who
gets behind the monitor here um look
these are the potential pets you can
meet
and i mean how can there's my dog
douglas oh my gosh look at his paw that
he's wearing a wig too there he goes
there he goes he's typing
yeah he's he's working the monitor there
so unless you know unless you're douglas
you're gonna need a foster parent to man
the keyboard
um and if all goes well then you can
meet up at the shelter to have an
in-person date and see if the fit works
as well as it did on zoom what do you
think about this russell well this is
such a duh of course thing right you
know there's animals in need all over
the country all over the world and now
you can zoom with them or facetime or as
they call it muzzle time
one on one but what a great opportunity
you know if you can't find the right
animal near you maybe it's across the
country and this connects you so i love
this i just think the next time you say
how was your zoom calling you can say he
was a real dog it actually could be a
good thing
[Music]
you